vor wenigen wochen noch hätten sich
solche umfragezahlen wie ein lottogewinn
angefühlt die spd hat wieder grund zur
zuversicht in der poleposition wenige
runden vor der ziellinie und die
konkurrenz mächtig hinterher also alles
schon gelaufen dazu jetzt die phoenix
runde im umfragehoch woher kommt der
aufwind der spd
[Musik]
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst hinzugeschaltet helene prof ski
parlamentskorrespondent in der
frankfurter allgemeine zeitung hier in
berlin und hans ulrich jörges freier
journalist und buchautor
hier im studio begrüße ich die
politikwissenschaftlerin andrea römmele
professorin an der hertie school in
berlin und nico sigel ist bei uns
geschäftsführer von infratest dimap
das wahlforschungsinstitut
ermittelt unter anderem für die ard den
deutschlandtrend also die regelmäßigen
sonntagsfragen die im moment ja so
wichtig sind frau bobrowski kann man ihn
sagen olaf scholz ist auf einer solo
tournee mit einem sozialdemokratischen
begleitorchester
finde ich weit hinten im halbdunkel der
bühne
na ja bemerkenswert ist ja jedenfalls
mal dass die sozialdemokraten seit sehr
langer zeit ist geschafft haben ihren
eigenen kandidaten nicht kurz vor der
wahl zu meucheln nämlich genau das von
mir gesehen bei steinbrück noch
intensiver bei martin schulz vor vier
jahren dass die schärfsten angriffe
gegen den sozialdemokratischen
kanzlerkandidaten immer aus den eigenen
reihen kam und erstaunlicherweise ist ja
trotz dieser dir dieses schwierigen
prozess den wir 2009 10 gesehen haben
bei der auswahl von neuen
parteivorsitzenden wo man ja das gefühl
hatte also wo es darum ging wird die
gruppe verlängert oder nicht und all
dieses schwierige debatten und wo dann
zwei vorsitzende gewählt wurden die
überhaupt nicht mit olaf scholz am
anfang gut konnten und so weiter die
partei hat es geschafft
erstaunlicherweise zusammenzustehen hat
vor einem jahr nun schon die
kanzlerkandidaten
ausgemacht und seitdem wogt keiner mehr
auf und dann gab es teilweise die these
die anderen stehen gefesselt an
irgendwelchen bäumen aber sie melden
sich ja nun doch auch vermehrt in
talkshows zu wort und fallen im eigenen
kandidaten nicht in den rücken und
jedenfalls das ist würde ich mal sagen
in den letzten jahren bei den
sozialdemokraten einmalig und sicherlich
einer der gründe bekommen bestimmt zu
den anderen auch noch aber einer der
gründe für ihren jetzigen erfolg in den
umfragen also bei den sozialdemokraten
etwas neues nämlich kein friendly fire
wie früher promille haben denn die
wählerinnen und wähler des 26 9
erwartungen die die spd im moment am
besten erfüllen kann naja was wir jetzt
in der korona zeit 10 im wahlkampf in
der korona zeit ist dass viele trends im
wahlkampf die wir in den letzten
wahlperioden schon gesehen haben sich
verstärken eine noch stärkere
personalisierung ist ein faktor aber
auch ein noch stärkerer drang zu
politischen führung also der kandidat
und seine führungsqualitäten spielen
eine noch größere rolle und ursprünglich
hat sich ja die union auf ein duell mit
annalena baerbock
vorbereitet jetzt ist es olaf scholz und
die führungserfahrung des vize kanzlers
er ist natürlich sehr viel stärker als
die jetzt des herausforderers laschet
und das schlägt ganz klar zu buche herr
jörges wie hoch ist denn der anteil von
annalena baerbock und armin laschet an
den höhenflügen von olaf scholz
sehr gute frage das ist wenn man es über
die einzige begründung für den höhenflug
also die relative stärke von olaf scholz
ist eine funktion ein ergebnis der
schwäche der beiden anderen also die
grünen und die union haben nach meiner
überzeugung die falschen kandidaten
aufgestellt annalena baerbock hat sich
durch
ungeschicklichkeiten manipulationen an
ihrem lebenslauf einem
zusammengeschusterten buch viel
vertrauen verspielt das kriegt sie auch
nicht zurück und
der cdu-kandidat der unionskandidat hat
schon zu beginn seiner öffentlichen
wahrnehmung bundesweit als es um die
krone politik gegen den kurs verlor das
hat ihn bis heute vertrauen gekostet er
war ja anfangs zu sehen ein
ministerpräsident der öffnen wollte der
also weg wollte fand er regierten corona
politik jedenfalls war das seine
erklärte absicht die hat nicht lange
gehalten dann fing er an zu trudeln hat
hin und her die seiten gewechselt und
hat in dieser langen zeit der korona
politik keine kontur gewonnen während
die politik im wesentlichen von angela
merkel und markus söder gemacht worden
ist das ist auch so oder so stark also
armin laschet ist ein
außerhalb von nordrhein-westfalen
schwach und schwankend wahrgenommener
mann der eine fehlbesetzung ist muss man
klar sagen wenn die union den markus
söder aufgestellt hätte sähe die
situation völlig anders aus und auch die
situation der spd mit olaf scholz gut
wie das ausgegangen wäre möglicherweise
das heißt nicht möglicherweise sondern
sicherlich spekulationen aber vielleicht
auch interessant wenn wir uns nach die
konstellation mal ansehen her sie
gewöhnt sie sich über ihre unterlagen
beugen denn so dass meinungs- und
stimmungsbild der deutschen erforschen
könnten sie dem cateringservice des
willy brandt hauses schon empfehlen für
den abend des 26 den sekt in den
kühlschrank zu stellen also ich würde
sagen vorbestellen sollten alle parteien
für den 26 denn wir wissen ja nach 18
uhr feiern sich alle auch die
wahlverlierer erklären ja jede
niederlage hat sich einige relativ viel
sagen das ist gerade der eine braucht
mehr sekt als der andere es ist völlig
offen wie diese waren am 26
ausgeht die ja der abstand im moment
zwischen spd und cdu csu ist zu gering
als dass man jetzt schon sagen könnte
die messe ist gelesen es ist in der
demokratie im parteienwettbewerb immer
nullsummenspiel es ist auch ein stück
weit müßig zu sagen ob jetzt die cdu/csu
und die grünen die falschen
spitzenkandidaten haben man hätte
genauso gut über die wahlkämpfe zu 17 23
10 sagen die spd hatte die falschen
spitzenkandidaten fakt ist tatsächlich
dass der unionskandidat unheimliche
schwierigkeiten hat weil seine
popularität zu werten dass die grünen
kanzlerkandidaten einige fehler gemacht
hat allerdings zuletzt auch dem trio bei
ard und zdf stärker geworden ist aber
das entscheidende an diesem wahlkampf
ist eines der spd zu geschlossen wie
seit langer langer zeit nicht mehr
zweiter sie setzt auf themen die weit in
der bürgerlichen mitte der gesellschaft
anklang finden das thema mindestlohn 12
euro sicherheit von renten wir haben im
februar 2009 10 die menschen befragt
sind sie für die anhebung eines
mindestlohns auf 12 euro 70 prozent der
unions wähler haben gesagt ja und diese
lücke in der sozial und
arbeitsmarktpolitik die schöpft die spd
mit dem souveränen kompetenten
spitzenkandidat bislang gut aus
gut das hat ja dann offenbar dass
adenauer haus nicht erreicht
informationen die sie da herausbekommen
haben eins fällt ja wirklich auf wir
fragen jetzt woher kommt dieser aufwind
also ich kann mich nicht erinnern dass
so schnell sich so schnell die und so
heftig die die die zahlen die zustimmung
auch dass die sonntagsfrage so
verschoben haben innerhalb kurzer zeit
die spd von 15 auf 25 prozent analog die
union und die
bündnisgrünen verluste etwa in gleicher
größenordnung ist das sehr wohl schon
genannt was gründe sind gibt es aber in
dieser schnelligkeit in dieser
heftigkeit gibt es dafür eine erklärung
ja es gibt nachlassende parteibindung
die stärkere personalisierung im
wahlkampf sind verschiedene faktoren
aber wir hatten auch schon 2002 und 2005
plus 7 prozentpunkte bei der spd rudolf
scharping hat 1994 ein zehn punkte
vorsprung gegenüber der union verspielt
also das war über etwas längere strecken
des wahlkampfes aber in diesem wahlkampf
kam halt hinzu dass die cdu ihre
nachfolge frage bei der kanzlerschaft
nicht rechtzeitig angegangen ist das
dann es zu einem sehr harten wettkampf
kamen zwischen söder und lasse das
goutieren konservative wähler nicht
wirklich und das dann strategie und
kampagne eigentlich nicht so vorbereitet
waren nur man spürt auch zumindest hat
im letzten wochenende das jetzt ein
kleiner ruck durch die partei geht nicht
also eines geschlossener beim träger
hatte asche doch etwas besser
abgeschnitten als manche erwartet haben
deshalb vorsicht mit dem champagner und
dem sekt oder aber auch schon mit dem
bestellen bei der frage ist natürlich
für waren niedere eine frage ob sie
schon machen sollten
wenn ich da widersprechen darf ich
glaube nicht dass die stärke von olaf
scholz mit programmatischen
dingen im auftritt der spd zu tun am
mindestlohn beispielsweise angela merkel
geht und ich glaube dass die
entscheidende währung das vertrauen ist
die wähler suchen eine figur der sie
wieder vertrauen können das ist armin
laschet nicht das ist auch anna lena
berbalk nicht das ist in seiner art
aufzutreten der mann ist ja
wie soll man sagen unerschütterlich in
allem auch in angriffen ausgesetzt ist
das ist olaf scholz und zwar ziemlich
einsam die programmatik der spd ich
glaube nicht dass die leute überhaupt
auf wahlprogramme viel achten das haben
sie in der vergangenheit zu oft erlebt
dass dinge die versprochen worden sind
dann später nicht eingehalten wurden
also vorsicht damit und ich muss
hinzufügen
auch da verzeihung herr siegel ich habe
gewisse zweifel an der tragfähigkeit der
umfragen die wir seit ein paar wochen
lesen das ist für mich insbesondere
deutlich geworden als das
allensbach-institut die union bei 25
prozent angesiedelt hat und in derselben
woche das forsa-institut bei 19
irgendwas stimmt da nicht ich wäre sehr
vorsichtig das schon für einen
belastbaren
ausdruck der stimmung im volk zu nehmen
möglicherweise ist es ja so dass es
deswegen auch nicht so belastbar ist
weil wir ja mit den briefwahlen auch der
befehl brief wählerinnen und wählern
auch noch ein problem haben jetzt ist
die frage also es gibt ja nicht mal so
sehr um das die programmatik also sie
haben jetzt mal punkte genannt wie
renten und mindestlohn sondern um die
person olaf scholz oder ergänzt sich das
im moment für die spd besonders gut das
ergänzt sich für die spd besonders gut
es geht ja in wahlkämpfen um den
perfekten fit zwischen partei
kandidat und programm ja und natürlich
herr jörges ist es so dass die wenigsten
wähler übrigens auch die wenigsten
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
die parteiprogramme von vorne bis hinten
lesen das heißt aber noch lange nicht
dass themen
keine rolle spielen es die themen
spielen eine ganz große rolle klima die
nachwirkungen die nachwehen von corona
soziale gerechtigkeit und polarisierung
digitalisierung das sind themen die im
wahlkampf überall virulent sind und die
frage ist eben welche per welcher person
wird die größte
problemlösungskompetenz zugeschrieben
und das große thema vertrauen das ist
der erste punkt den ich machen möchte
und der zweite punkt herr jörges da
möchte ich ihnen widersprechen was sie
eingangs gesagt haben dass die stärke
von olaf scholz letztendlich mit der
schwäche der beiden anderen kandidaten
zu erklären es dem ist ein mini bisschen
spielt es eine rolle aber ich würde
sagen der große anteil ist letztendlich
der ausnahmsweise mal extrem gut
orchestrierte spd-wahlkampf der ja schon
im august des letzten jahres angefangen
hat weil die spd als erste partei damals
belächelt den kanzler kandidaten
aufgestellt hat damals ist mir noch
davon ausgegangen also werden es
überhaupt 15 prozent werden aber dieser
wahlkampf verfängt jens und die union
darauf sind sie ja auch eingegangen herr
siegel hat mit ihrem wahlkampf viel zu
spät angefangen weil sie auch keinen
kandidaten hatte dementsprechend spät
wurden die themen nachgeliefert und wir
haben ein ganz ein großer teil der
bevölkerung der unentschlossen ist er
keine partei identifikation mehr hat und
gerade für diesen teil der bevölkerung
spielen wahlkämpfe eine ganz zentrale
gamal das stichwort von ihnen
orchestrierung seit august 2020 und
timing aufnehmen frau bukowski ist ein
olaf scholz der der der richtige mann
zur richtigen zeit hat er genügend
geduld wiesen um im richtigen moment zur
stelle zu sein war das geplant oder
spielte ihm da auch in der zufälle gibts
ja bekanntlich nicht spielte ihm da auch
viele andere externe faktoren eine rolle
naja also zum einen ich glaube da kommen
für jene dinge zusammen zum einen ich
meine schon dass die stärke von urlaub
stolz mit der schwäche der beiden
anderen kandidaten zusammen hängt man
kann es ja auch sehen dass urlaubsort in
meine die spd stand bis vor wenigen
wochen also noch bis zum sommer bei 15
prozent und zwar stabil das ganze jahr
durch das sie schon ihren
kanzlerkandidaten nominiert hatten und
es stimmt natürlich dass dann irgendwann
diese plakataktion gestartet sind und
man jedenfalls in berlin den eindruck
hat an jeder zweite straßenlaterne hängt
ein plakat von olaf scholz
das kann gut sein dass das bei den
wählern verfängt aber es ist doch so
dass der der denn ich sage mal
niedergangen und in umfragen der grünen
setzte ungesetzte kurz vorher ein und
der cdu auch also da gibt es ja schon
jedenfalls meine korrelation
interessant ist ja auch zu sehen dass
die cdu ja ich hab's ja vorhin gesagt
der spd so geschlossen die cdu mache
jetzt im grunde die fehler die die spd
jahrelang gemacht hat sie kann sich
nicht für einen kandidaten entscheiden
dann sie aus den eigenen reihen heftige
kritik am eigenen kandidaten und das
kommt ja nicht nur von seiten der csu
sondern eben auch von den
landesverbänden die sich ja vorher in
dieser auseinandersetzung söder laschet
alle schon klar positioniert hatten und
jetzt quasi mit geballter faust in der
tasche im wahlkampf machen müssen und
wir sehen halt dass das nicht richtig
funktioniert ein dritter punkt finde ich
auch noch interessant in der gemenge
lage und der ist eben dass die sehnsucht
der deutschen ganz offensichtlich
mehrheitlich nicht die veränderung ist
das war ja die botschaft auf die grünen
gesetzt hatten einen aufbruch eine
veränderung eine anfangs haben sie immer
noch das wort radikal gesagt also eine
radikale änderung des lebens aber auch
viele andere bereiche der politik
insgesamt und
das ist etwas das offensichtlich zu
ängsten führt auch zu zu
dazu ablehnung und und dann ist eben die
frage wer ist also diese politik merck
ist ja oft
kritisiert wurde dass sie überhaupt
nicht visionär sei und im grunde nur
verwaltet und so weiter wir sehen jetzt
dass diese dieser politik die eigentlich
insgesamt ganz gut ankommt das halb so
das ist jetzt immer steht
geraden kontinuität
das holster entwickelt hat merkel 20
also eigentlich derjenige der merkels
politik weiter führt mit gewissen
neuerungen mit einem gewissen aufprall
aufbruch mit einer gewissen und krise
sozialdemokratie das hat auch verfangen
aus ihrer sicht ja genau ich finde halt
ist es relativ wenig auch noch dabei
also man muss gar nicht dieses bild von
scholz mit der raute zitieren sondern er
ist insgesamt in seiner ganzen art zu
kommunizieren
in seiner ganzen art zu sein also dieses
deftige das ja auch angela merkel hat
hat er auch als er kann angriffe gut
parieren er ist gilt als verlässlich man
unterstellt irgendwie im leben dass er
irgendwas macht um sich selbst zu
bereichern oder ähnliche dinge deswegen
verfangen auch diese ganzen vorwürfe die
gegen ihn im raum stehen nicht waka
comex und so weiter er geht eben als
verlässliche person an eine wo man wo
man weiß woran man ist ja also dieses
dieser slogan von merkel wirkt wir sie
kennen mich das ist jetzt bei olaf
scholz sagt sie kennen mich als
vizekanzler und er steigt ein in diese
linie ich bin eigentlich der natürliche
nachfolger angela merkels das
interessante ist ja dass der cdu
kandidat der im grunde genommen in
dieser reihe steht ja das nicht ausfüllt
und jetzt auftritt als sei er der
angreifer der aus der opposition den
sozusagen kanzler angreift im in trier
fand ich das ganz schön zu sehen hatte
man den eindruck der herausforderer ist
im grunde genommen armin laschet der
amtsbonus inhaber ist
läuft da falsch siegel der also der
armin laschet ist
olaf scholz ist eigentlich der erbe von
von angela merkel und
damit laschet muss sich in sap fühlen
also olaf scholz ist weder eine angela
merkel 2 0 noch der erbe und diese
ruhige und auch souveränität und eher
kühle
abziehen die wahlkampfstrategie hat doch
um gottes willen ich angela merkel
erfunden die gab es schon mitte der 70er
jahre in person von helmut schmidt der
plakatieren ließ sicherheit für
deutschland helmut schmidt also wir tun
gerade sogar allem was was olaf scholz
tut und angeblich hans ulrich jörges
volker nicht ohne olaf scholz wäre das
umfragehoch der spd sehr wahrscheinlich
nicht entstanden alles was ich sage ist
es müssen verschiedene rädchen
ineinandergreifen die person muss die
richtige sein sie muss weit ins
bürgerliche lager hinein attraktiv sein
erfahrung und ruhe in unsicheren zeiten
ausstrahlen wir machen als eliten einen
ganz großen fehler auch das diskutieren
wir immer in diesen räumen wir bräuchten
noch mehr reformen schneller beim
klimawandel schneller weil der
digitalisierung die große mehrheit der
deutschen weiß dass wir vor einer dekade
von große unsicherheit stehen und in
dieser situation ist es klar dass jemand
der sicherheit und ruhe ausstrahlt
grundsätzlich als krisenmanager der über
verschiedene politikfelder ja später
eine koalition führen muss verschiedene
interessen ausgleichen muss was man
angela merkel immer vorgeworfen hat ist
eigentlich im grundgesetz vorgesehen als
ressort prinzip der bundesregierung und
da punktet olaf scholz und da hatte die
union bis hier und heute probleme
vorsicht wir haben noch zehn bis elf
tage wahlkampf und in der zeit kann viel
passieren und deshalb vorsicht mit denen
jetzt schon finalen diagnosen dass die
union alles falsch gemacht hat und die
spd alles andere
mängel so parat dass man das fell des
bären nicht verteilen sollte vorher
erledigt
sind dran ja ich möchte der these
widersprechen dass die menschen keine
veränderung wollen die menschen wollen
veränderungen weil die zustände in denen
sie jetzt leben ganz klar nicht mehr
verlängert sich also ich will nur die
zustände an den schulen beleuchten und
die die katastrophale digitalisierung
des landes jeder weiß dass ich was
ändern muss in vielerlei hinsicht von
der klimapolitik gar nicht zu reden aber
natürlich suchen die menschen in diesen
zeiten eines umbruchs eines neuanfangs
würde ich sogar sagen jemanden dem sie
zutrauen den zu gestalten und das ist
eben nicht armin laschet armin laschet
ist der kandidat des weiter so der hat
keine eigenen ideen geäußert und damit
durch der es vielmehr der kandidaten
weiter so um als olaf scholz war und ist
müssen ja eigentlich er dann eigentlich
entlastet besser da hat schon schlägt
reform vor die mehrheitlich akzeptiert
er hätte das ist entscheidend ist die
leute wollen veränderungen aber er hat
die bessere angebot in der mehrheit der
bevölkerung ist gar kein widerspruch ja
das land braucht wandel bei digitale und
umwelt aber die menschen brauchen auch
eine sicherheit dass derjenige der diese
reformen ansteuert das durchaus mit
souveränität und rationalität macht als
darf ich eins noch jagen wäre hätte die
union
markus söder aufgestellt und die grünen
herrnhaag sehr die situation im
wahlkampf und zwischen den kandidaten
vollkommen anders aus ich halte es für
ausgeschlossen dass dann olaf scholz
vorne läge dann legen nach allem was wir
wissen markus söder vorne weil der aus
bayern heraus während der korona politik
eben viele anhänger gewonnen hat das
sind zum teil leute die früher auf märz
gesetzt haben die völlig märz aber
verloren hat ich will jedenfalls sagen
es haben zwei parteien die falschen
kandidaten aufgestellt und davon
profitiert olaf scholz mit den richtigen
kandidaten läge die union vermutlich
weit vorne und auch die grünen wären
stärker gut jetzt machen die runde
weiter ball fördermitteln ja ich wollte
noch mal ganz kurz nachhaken bei dem was
herr siegel vor hinaus geführt hat und
bist du noch mal unterstreichen
dass wir einfach noch zehn tage wenn ich
richtig rechne bis zum wahltermin habe
ich mein ich sage immer wir wählen nicht
am 26 september der letzte tag an dem
wir wählen ist der 26 september das ist
ja für die wahlkampfstrategen wahnsinnig
schwierig macht hier die leute zu
mobilisieren versetzt zu mobilisieren
was wir bei der union jetzt durchaus
sehen ist dass manche dinge jetzt
greifen ja also der der die
parteitagsrede in nürnberg die armin
laschet gegeben hat hat ihm sichtlich
und der applaus den er dann von den
delegierten gekriegt hatte ich meine es
war am nächsten tag im trie l ja
sichtbar wie sich wie viel sicherer er
aufgetreten ist er war ruhiger das hat
man ganz klar gemerkt die partei wirkte
geschlossene und da wie gesagt es sind
noch zehn tage und da kann noch viel
passieren
ich wollte einfach auch noch mal ein
paar wahlkämpfe
uns vor augen rufen wo wirklich in
kurzer zeit die dinge gedreht worden ich
meine zweimal in rheinland-pfalz lag der
cdu-kandidat beziehungsweise die
cdu-kandidatin deutlich vorne und zwar
deutlich vorne und dann hat sich im
laufe von es war immer jetzt mehr als
drei vier wochen aber in zwei monaten
hat sich alles nochmal gedreht was ich
sagen möchte ist wahlkämpfe haben eine
wirkung darf ich das weiter verlängern
diesen gedanken bobrowski wenn wir jetzt
sagen was könnte eigentlich noch schief
laufen für die spd wie gesagt es gibt so
eine kleine trendumkehr in den letzten
tagen wie belastbar das ist kann man
vielleicht noch nicht sagen was was
könnte es auch schief laufen für die spd
die sich von denen sich jetzt eine jahr
einige er auf der siegerstraße denen
ja ich vielleicht noch kurz vorher zum
thema zum thema veränderung da haben mir
die kollegen mir widersprochen ich
glaube trotzdem dass es das da was dran
ist dass der wunsch nach veränderung
nicht besonders groß ist und ich glaube
dass man ganz klar unterscheiden muss
zwischen der tatsache dass veränderung
objektiv notwendig ist und die
wissenschaftler dazu raten und natürlich
auch ist diverse missstände gibt an den
schulen in den gesundheitsämtern und so
wirklich ständig berichtet wird und dass
trotzdem der wähler in der situation der
wahl sich fragten möchte ich eigentlich
mein leben radikal verändern möchte ich
wirklich auf möglicherweise dinge
verzichten und so weiter und da ist halt
selbst wenn es gegen besseres wissen ist
hat sich herausgestellt dass es ist
jedenfalls ich auch die analyse
innerhalb der grünen partei die ja immer
feststellen sie setzen auf diese
veränderung botschaft und kurz vor den
wahlen geht es runter und zwar
unabhängig davon auch wenn die
kandidaten keine sehr schweren die
führung habe machen die grünen aber
nicht mehr erste mal bei der
bundestagswahl
genau das hatte deshalb weil eben dieser
wald diese auch weil diese botschaft wir
wollen dieses land verändern da sind
eben die beharrungskräfte in diesem land
doch sehr groß ihre frage was kann noch
schiefgehen ich meine wir sehen jetzt
natürlich dass
seit einigen wochen nun olaf scholz eben
als der der große gegner wahrgenommen
wird und zwar von den grünen aber
natürlich vor allem auch von der union
die musste natürlich ihr konzept
umstellen dieses duell schwarz grünen
gibt es nicht mehr sondern es gibt das
duell schwarz rot und jetzt wird eben
auch scholz sehr viel aggressiver
angegangen um den man sich vorher
eigentlich nicht so gekümmert hat und
jetzt gibt es die internen fragen warum
haben wir eigentlich mit comics mehr zum
thema gemacht aus sicht der cdu eher
warum nicht wirecard warum ist der stolz
sozusagen mit diesen dingen so gut
durchgekommen die sind nicht an ihm
haften geblieben und jetzt wird er eben
sehr viel stärker attackiert das haben
wir im duell gesehen die frage ist nur
und da würde ich vor e mail
widersprechen
die frage ist nur wirkt armin laschet
der jetzt so angreift damit wirklich
überzeugend ich habe da ehrlich gesagt
meine zweifel neue armin laschet
eigentlich der mann der fas wohnung ist
eigentlich der mann der moderaten töne
der mann des ausgleichs und jetzt macht
das ein bisschen auf den kleinen
wadenbeißer und man fragt sich also das
lässt natürlich auch die wähler
irritiert zurück die sich fragen wer ist
eigentlich dieser armin laschet der
jetzt auf einmal eine völlig neue rolle
angenommen hat die so ein bisschen auf
gestülpt auch wirkt und mein gefühl ist
armin laschet spricht momentan vor allem
zu seiner eigenen partei und auch der
csu also zu den schwesterparteien wird
heute bei der bei der spd bleiben das
ist ja auch das thema der sendung ich
kann nur ganz kurz was erwidern ich gebe
ihnen recht dass die dass die rolle die
herr laschet in diesen tri ace einem zu
als angreifer im ersten teil als
rudern der angreifer im zweiten teil als
etwas ruhigerer angreifer ich gebe ihnen
vollkommen recht dass das eine rolle ist
die ihm nicht steht die auch die auch
nicht authentisch
wirkt aber es ist die rolle in die ihn
der wahlkampf und auch die fehlende
strategie gebracht hatte wollte jetzt
armin laschet bin ich selbst schon
durcheinander
vielen dank olaf scholz als erster
sozusagen im ziel ankommt oder anschlägt
wir sind jetzt gerade schon stichworte
gefallen comex wirecard und da gibt es
noch die financial intelligence unit das
ist geldwäschebekämpfung das sind
bereiche die für die olaf scholz
verantwortlich sind es geht um
bilanzbetrug im einen fall dann
steuerbetrug im großen stil bei comics
wo ganz reiche sich kriminell an der
steuerkasse bedient waren auf kosten der
steuerzahler vor allem der kleinen und
mittleren die das ja mitfinanzieren
müssen und auch bei der geldwäsche geht
es ja darum geld abzuzweigen sozusagen
den staat die gesellschaft ärmer zu
machen dass alles in
verantwortungsbereich eines spd
politikers der ja genau für das
gegenteil steht nämlich gerade die
kleinen und mittleren einkommen
also die menschen aus der aus der mittel
und unterschicht zu stützen das ist ja
dass die klassische spd klientel das
scheint ihnen ja nicht völlig nicht auf
die füße zu fallen diese dieser
sachverhalt woran liegt das ja wurde
auch schon von teflon gesprochen ja aber
es also 1 1 teflon kandidat ist prallt
an ihm ab es ist so man man kennt olaf
scholz ja es fällt ja auf einen
resonanzboden bei ihm
man verbindet ganz viele dinge mit mit
olaf scholz aber das haftet nicht hätte
man jetzt eine andere kandidatin wir
hatten dass er bei annalena baerbock die
nicht bekannt war die menschen kannten
annalena baerbock mich da habe da haftet
so einer 1 1 letztendlichen
handwerklicher die themen sehr komplex
sind ganz ganz kurz das würde auch sagen
um zu verstehen was man gelernt aber
ganz gut zu ende bringen daher hafte so
ein handwerklicher fehler auf einer
projektionsfläche wo sonst nichts
anderes drauf ist wir kennen annalena
baerbock nicht als großes problem
das ist bei olaf scholz anders ist es
der erste punkt der zweite punkt ist
natürlich dass diese themen wahnsinnig
komplex sind und medial deswegen auch
nicht so gut transportierbar und dritter
punkt ich bin mir hundert prozent sicher
dass die wahlkampfzentrale der spd auch
ein ganz krasses gender cutting betreibt
also aktiv versucht dieses thema von der
agenda zu halten indem sie eben andere
negative andere geschichten erzählt und
ich glaube diese drei dinge
zusammengenommen machen
sich auf den dänischen gegner zu leicht
gefallen das entscheidende ist doch noch
mal auf hans ulrich jörges früh kommt
die spd hat natürlich gesehen dass die
zwei anderen kandidaten jetzt mit großen
popularitäts problem verknüpft sind und
deshalb fährt sie mit inhalten
angereichert eine sehr starke zuspitzung
des wahlkampfes auf ihren
kanzlerkandidaten weise gefragt haben wo
lauern die risiken natürlich fährt die
spd implizit und explizit an den
kampagne die sagt zweitstimme ist
kanzler stimme ist also olaf stimme und
deshalb wird auch die schwäche von armin
laschet auf der reststrecke des
wahlkampfes nicht entscheidend sein weil
die union im moment die strategie
gewechselt hat weg von einer
personalisierung des wahlkampfs die
eigentlich typisch für cdu/csu ist aus
der geschichte der wahlkämpfe hin zur
auseinandersetzung zu sagen wirtschafts
und sozialpolitik und natürlich den
schülern der vor einem möglichen rot rot
grünen bündnis und deshalb sind jetzt
die strategien bei der spd ganz klar
zweitstimme ist olaf stimme und
zweitstimme ist stimme für die cdu so
ihr lieben älteren wählerinnen und
wähler die häufiger per ohne auch wählen
geht doch bitte noch hin und welt die
union wende zweitstimme olaf stimme ist
herr jörges
war kann es noch passieren dass da olaf
scholz ins schlingern kommt und das wird
ja dann tatsächlich auf ihren und auf
die spd wiederum zurückfallen
es gibt bei der letzten affären es jetzt
mal da geht es um die razzia im
bundesfinanzministerium schon ein
unterschied zu comics und dem bayer grad
zusammenbruch das ist alles kompliziert
frau blättern sie völlig recht aber in
dem letzten fall wirkt sich die
komplexität der materie gegen olaf
scholz aus weil die leute gar nicht mehr
genau verstehen aber schon gut verstehen
dass da ein ministerium durchsucht
worden ist und
das ist eine gefährliche sache für
scholz ich glaube auch dass ich kann mir
erlauben das offen zu sagen so wie ich
es empfinde ich habe den eindruck dass
dieser razzia in der schlussphase des
wahlkampfs auch parteipolitisch
initiiert worden ist uns mit gedacht
worden ist dann folgt noch ein
ermittlungsverfahren gegen stolzen
engsten berater hatte er einen auszug
aus dem untersuchungsausschuss
veröffentlicht hat um den leuten klar zu
machen haben sie ja eigentlich geht
schon gibt es ein ermittlungsverfahren
ich finde dass die justiz in der
schlussphase von wahlkämpfen mit so
etwas sofern es nicht um wirklich
schwerwiegende vorwürfe gegen den
politiker überhaupt geht und da geht es
ja nicht um ihn sondern da geht es um
eine behörde sehr vorsichtig sein muss
und eine razzia in der schlussphase die
dass das missverständnis auslösen kann
olaf scholz habe ihr etwas verbockt das
ist eigentlich nicht zulässig und das
müsste man auch offen diskutieren ich
halte das für völlig verfehlt und das
ist eine sehr gefährliche sache für ihn
eben weil es niemand genau versteht aber
jeder versteht genau was es bedeutet
wenn die polizei irgendwann einstimmig
jeden fall zu das heißt also dass da
möglicherweise für olaf scholz noch
probleme aufkommen die sich der
politische gegner
zu nicht irgendwann gibt es einigkeit
hier darf ich ein aspekt noch ansprechen
wir haben schon vorhin schon mal
angedeutet dass olaf scholz ja der
ursprünglich gar nicht als
parteivorsitzender gewollt war ja einer
partei jetzt kanzler als
kanzlerkandidatin die eigentlich
politisch erfinden linker eingestellt
ist als er selbst könnte es denn sein
dass die linken nach der wahl die
rechnung präsentiert dass die linken in
der spd die rechnung präsentieren für
das stillhalten und die
toleranz gegenüber olaf scholz dass das
kann durchaus sein dass es kommt aber
auf der anderen seite ist olaf scholz ja
dann auch in der ganze anderen position
also sollte er die spd wirklich als
erste über die zielgerade bringen und
dann auch noch
gute koalitions also gute
sondierungsgespräche und gute
koalitionsverhandlungen führen ist ja in
einer komplett anderen situation
und gesprächssituation dem linken flügel
der partei gegenüber na gut das so
erwarten helmut schmidt und gerhard
schröder auch und ihr schicksal ist am
ende bekannt letztendlich es gibt ja
auch durchaus gegenspieler könnte es zum
beispiel darauf hinauslaufen dass jemand
der in der spd großen einfluss hat und
sich jetzt auch zurückhält und olaf
scholz unterstützt kevin kühnert eines
tages gegen lafontaine macht wie das
damals lafontaine gegenüber schuldner
gemacht hat dass diese gegensätze wieder
aufbrechen denn sie sind ja eigentlich
jetzt durch den wahlkampf zuwider sie
sind durch den wahlkampf zugedeckt ganz
klar aber der wille zur macht und
das also eben nicht opposition ist mist
er sondern der wille zur macht und dann
über die macht gestalten kann so einen
laden auch ein stück weit und eine
zeitlang zusammen halten aber dass man
natürlich liebt diese diese diese klippe
jazz diese konfliktlinien gut moderieren
muss das ist vollkommen klar ganz kurz
angeschlagen
noch eine frage an herrn sie die wir
sind ja ein sender von ard und zdf dazu
team wir jetzt mal ihre kollegen vom zdf
firma forschungsgruppe wahlen
letzte woche auch gefragt haben was ist
für die menschen nicht und da kann etwas
ganz erstaunliches ist nicht das klima
das wichtigste thema sondern soziale
gerechtigkeit stärkt das wieder auch die
position gerade der linken spd denn das
ist ja ein uhr sozialdemokratisches
anliegen ja das thema klima und umwelt
ist schon bei vielen menschen auch sehr
sehr wichtig und das ist genau aber es
gibt schon integriert dass auch herr
jörges zurecht da wissen alle menschen
da müssen weitreichende veränderungen
implementiert werden aber soziale
gerechtigkeit ist wieder wichtiger
geworden und es ist einfach eine
schräglage in diesem wahlkampf weil die
cdu auch in ihrem kompetenzteam oder
ihrem zukunftsteam keinen ausgewiesenen
sozial und arbeitsmarktexperten hat das
wäre helmut kohl nie passiert hatte
norbert blüm er hatte horst seehofer der
letztendlich die kopfpauschale in der
gesetzlichen krankenversicherung
verhindert hat angela merkel hat das
schmerzlich lernen müssen dass wenn sie
nicht arbeitnehmer interessen bedient in
der mitte der gesellschaft die union
sich sehr schwertut electoral und
deshalb ist dieses thema soziale
gerechtigkeit wichtig und deshalb
deshalb funktioniert auch das mit dem
mindestlohn die meisten von uns sind da
doch gar nicht betroffen geschweige denn
die in dieser sendung aber das deckt
sich mit dem gerechtigkeitsempfinden die
überwiegende mehrheit der bevölkerung
genauso wie das thema sichere renten so
schwer dass dann auch nach der wahl
inhaltlich zu füllen sein wird wie das
anders reduziert werden wir sind jetzt
bei der frage bei der frage sind die
linken in der spd werden die durch die
bundestagswahl gestellt vorausgesetzt
die spd gewinnt oder stellen kanzler
werden die durch die bundestagswahl
gestärkt oder eher geschwächt
nein ich glaube geschwächt ich glaube
dass die bedeutung der spd als partei
sofern olaf scholz kanzler ist
erheblich relativiert wird olaf scholz
kann ja nur regieren wenn er
voraussichtlich zwei andere
koalitionspartner hat
voraussichtlich so jedenfalls
laufen die dinge die grünen und die fdp
das sind nun wiederum zwei sehr
unterschiedliche koalitionspartner und
wenn man eine halbwegs stabile regierung
haben will sollte man sich als spd genau
überlegen was man da noch an äußeren
konflikten hineinträgt in diese
koalition
ich glaube auch dass olaf scholz jede
möglichkeit hätte unter verweis auf die
beiden anderen koalitionspartner
zumutungen aus dem linken parteiflügel
oder sagen wir mal neutraler forderungen
aus dem linken parteiflügel
zurückzuweisen da wäre die fdp schon mal
nicht mit dabei also es ist für ihn
unter den gegebenen bedingungen sofern
er kanzler wird
einfacher zu regieren als es das für
gerd schröder war der eine sehr viel
stärkere eigenständige unruhigere spd
hinter sich hatte die sich auch in zwei
wesentlichen sozialpolitischen fragen
mit den grünen sehr gut ergänzt hat also
da gab es keinen stopp in der koalition
sondern da war er erstand offenem feuer
und so im feuer stehen wird olaf scholz
nicht mehr gut dann sind jetzt bei der
abteilung farbenlehre photobox de wenn
die umfragen die wir jetzt gerade kennen
schon ungefähr das wahlergebnis abbilden
also mit einer spd die die wahlen zum
salz stärkste partei
abschließt welche koalitionen sind da
denkbar und wie relativiert dann auch
wieder das was olaf scholz jetzt
versucht zu vermitteln wofür er steht
für die inhalte die wie gesagt bei ihm
etwas anderes sind als die von vielen in
seiner partei was bedeutet dann eben ein
solches ergebnis also ein möglicher
bundeskanzler olaf scholz denn auch für
die koalitionsbildung und was wird sich
da durchsetzen es gibt ja drei bis vier
koalitionsoptionen die durchaus denkbar
sind
ist vieles denkbar herr jörges gerade
angesprochen die ampel ist natürlich
denkbar mein gefühl ist dass die führung
der grünen und auch die führung der spd
nicht mit den linken wollen dass es den
also abgesehen mal von dem
außenpolitischen
diskrepanzen und es geht es auch darum
dass die linken einfach keinen nicht gut
sortiert sind nicht gut aufgestellt sind
und eben ein wahnsinniger wackelkandidat
wären so ein bündnis die fdp ist auch
natürlich in vielen punkten schwierig
geworden auf gar keinen fall
steuererhöhungen das wollen spd und
grüne
insofern gibt es in jeglichem also in
diesen beiden konstellationen sicherlich
schwierigkeiten vielleicht erleben wir
halte ich nicht für sehr wahrscheinlich
aber wer weiß eine neuauflage der großen
koalition hätte ich schon so oft gesagt
wurde ich halte das ortsschild punkt für
relativ müßig all diese man kann das
wirklich in jegliche richtung
spekulieren und am ende liegt es
vielleicht ein paar prozentpunkten am
ende steht vielleicht wieder jemand auch
vom tisch und sagt so kann ich das nicht
machen das ist da muss man glaube ich
wirklich den wahltag abwarten ein ding
vielleicht noch zur frage ihrer frage
nach den linken in der oder ein aspekt
eine frage der linken in der spd ich
glaube natürlich stimmt ist dass durch
dass der wahlkampf die partei stark
diszipliniert hat ein anderer punkt und
ein anderer grund ist allerdings dieser
gemeinsamen blick in den abgrund den die
spd vor einem jahr getätigt hat wo sie
wirklich das gefühl hatten wenn wir
jetzt nicht unsere zusammenreißen und
versuchen das steuer herumzureißen dann
wird sich die spd nicht dauerhaft in
deutschland als als wirkliche kraft
halten können und wenn man nach
frankreich schaut sieht man auch wie
auch eine stolze sozialistische partei
einfach von der bildfläche verschwinden
kann und das zeichnet sich durch
natürlich schon länger ab aber die ganz
das ganze ausmaß der gefahr wurde die
habe ich ungefähr vor allem der
sichtbaren dann hat man olaf scholz
aufgestellt und seitdem läuft es besser
und dann stimmt es natürlich auch dass
nach einer wahl die aussicht auf macht
die aussicht auf ein ministeramt oder
auf andere posten auch eine unglaublich
disziplinierende wirkung habt so dass
meine prognose heute wäre ich lasse mich
aber gerne nach der wahl eines besseren
belehren dass die spd
auch wirklich jetzt geschlossener ist
als sie früher war und dass das nicht
nur jetzt im wahlkampf vorgetäuscht dass
sich dieses diese selbstdisziplinierung
durchsetzt vor allen dingen für den
kanzlerkandidaten
beziehungsweise für die spd hat dann
olaf scholz freie hand auch bei der
frage mit wem er koalieren will auch bis
zur besetzung des bundeskabinetts hat er
ja schon gesagt lässt dass ich wie
seinerzeit in hamburg war allerdings die
absolute mehrheit gewonnen hatte von
niemandem reinreden
ist das ist ist er wirklich dann
derjenige der auch seiner partei sagt
wo's langgeht gut es ist für alle die
hier bei koalitionsverhandlungen dann am
tisch sitzen immer eine gratwanderung
also inwieweit lasse ich mich auf dem
kompromiss ein und all so was kann ich
zu hause
vor meiner partei vor meinen wählerinnen
und wählern eigentlich noch vertreten
und es bleibt auch für einen olaf scholz
sicherlich eine gratwanderung jetzt gibt
es ja die möglichkeit ganz kurzer jörges
es gibt ja noch die möglichkeit artikel
dass es tatsächlich die die stärkste
fraktion
möglicherweise gar nicht die regierung
bildet könnte ja zb für jamaika auch
erreichen es gibt in der bundesdeutschen
geschichte ja drei wahlen wo das ja auch
der fall war das 1969 1976 der fall und
auch 1980 wo die stärkste partei in die
opposition gegangen ist das waren andere
zeiten dass man auch andere
größenordnungen über dieser damals
sprechen mussten dort über die wir heute
sprechen müssen über die aktuellen
parteien aber ist das auch denkbar eine
koalition ohne die spd ohne stolz es
waren andere zeit mit der
sozialliberalen koalition weil die fdp
vor der wahl jeweils klar gesagt hat
wenn sie denn zum bundeskanzler wählen
würde und 1983 im märz auch klar gesagt
hat sie würde helmut kohl zum
bundeskanzler wählen und nicht hans
jochen vogel eise denkbar ist dass also
ich hoffe als staatsbürger und
politikwissenschaftler dass derjenige
der auf platz zwei landet auch wenn das
nur 0,5 prozentpunkte sind erst einmal
akzeptiert es ist gute tradition im
parlamentarischen prozess ist dass die
stärkste fraktion erst einmal den ersten
hat in der verhandlungsführung trotzdem
kann nicht parallel versuchen andere
regierungsbündnisse zu schmieden also
wir erinnern uns gerhard schröder hat
das eiskalt durchgezogen 2002 als die
spd 6002 stimmen vor der union lag
angela merkel 2005 in der legendären
berliner runde gerd schröder eiskalt
abblitzen lassen der versucht hat zu
sagen er sei ja der kanzler der herzen
und von der mehrheit der deutschen
gewollten sie hat ganz klar dieses
schmale parlamentarische mehrheit
genutzt um ein regierungsbündnis zu
bilden ich hoffe dass es einen guten
zweiten verlierer gibt das wäre für
unsere partner parlamentarische
demokratie jedenfalls von der normativen
seite durchaus wichtig erst ganz kurz
haben leider nur noch eine halbe minute
bitte
na ja ich wollte nur sagen dass es
abseits von dieser frage dass die dass
der sieger den fortgang der dinge
bestimmt auf einen kleinen vorsprung hat
gibt es in den parteien die sich auf
einer regierung vorbereiten überlegungen
die ganz abseits davon laufen
beispielsweise wird bei den liberalen
überlegt sich selbstständig mit den
grünen zu verständigen mit wem die
beiden parteien dann koalieren die
hoffnung ist natürlich dass sich fdp und
grüne für die union erklären das ist
allerdings glaube ich ein verwegener
wunschtraum da werden die grünen nicht
mitmachen aber man sieht dass da dass es
geht und dass man jetzt schon darüber
nachdenkt wie man die dinge hinterher
gestalten kann gut also es geht und dass
uns noch nicht so ganz genau und können
nur vermuten und spekulieren frau
bobrowski es wird sich niemand für ihre
äußerung und vermutungen jetzt nach der
wahl sagen das gilt für uns alle auch
dass wir abwarten ob wir da richtig
lagen das kann man in der phoenix runde
auch den nächsten zwei wochen und weit
darüber hinaus beobachten ich bedanke
mich bei andrea römmele bei nico sigel
bei helene begriff ski und bei hans
ulrich jörges diebe zuschauer morgen in
der phoenix runde im rahmen unseres
themenabends vor der bundestagswahl zum
thema steuern und wirtschaft eher titel
streit um finanzen steuern rauf oder
runter bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]